today we will be attempting one of the
hardest obstacle courses in all of
minecraft i'm prepared and to make it
even harder the entire time
arrows are going to be raining like
behind you guys that's a lot of
arrows there's no way to get through
that and i didn't tell you guys this but
whichever one of us finishes last
has to kiss my dirty socks
i will take off my sock if i lose i'll
kiss chris's sock
if one of you guys lose you have to kiss
it whoa i hate this so much
can i say no let's go in groups let's go
in groups uh i think
chris and chandler should go first all
right let's do a chance you guys have
three lives good luck
go ow ah that jumping doesn't work
chandler immediately chris lead the way
oh are you stuck i'm leading i'm leading
underneath the bridge i'm safe keep
going all right
baby through the barn there's a little
haystack boom boom boom
this is terrifying chris where are you
building a i'm building a bridge
i gotta eat underneath this bridge oh
dude i'm actually really good at this
i'm not gonna lie
carl you ready born ready jimmy carl
let's go on three
one two screw you oh you went on two
no i went on screw you actually and for
that reason
yay we did it we're so much better than
them yeah we did go first though
wait oh ow ow ow these arrows
ow oh okay give me my dog oh my gosh
i forgot to eat i forgot to eat before i
went dude you always got to eat
you know it's raining out
chris nope chris
oh my god who's licking us
all right let me through guys stop being
mean all right you got it
all right next time me and carl go first
i'm just putting that out there all
right
all right it's out there yeah
nobody wants to kiss the dirty sock hey
chris give me some give me some meat
though all right
you have to finish the course yeah yeah
yeah your mom has to finish the course
she already went to school don't worry
jimmy you're doing great yeah unlike you
i'm not a baby that had to sit there and
eat food
well i mean i didn't die all right
now let's proceed to the second course
so far i'm the only one down to life
okay chandler chris drop all your steak
you have to do it without steak nobody
gets it
if they still have steak in their
inventory let me know and i'm gonna make
them literally eat a sock
everyone agree if someone's cheating
they have to eat a side all right i'll
do it away
all right let's all go at the same time
ready i thought you were going first
it's not even
the heroine yeah wait
no it i was coming back
wait look carl has steak wait somebody
just gave me a sink i swear to god
somebody just gave me
carl carl do you want to eat a sock
i really stop who keeps it at the state
all right let's go boys all right let's
do it who's going carl go first i'm
scared
yeah you're not carl all right let's get
it
oh no chalice gonna have to eat a sock
oh no i'm gonna have to eat a sock ah
i'm so good i love parkour i trained on
twitch for this
bro it's this it's only luck i'm eating
no it's not
luck i'm dodging the arrows can learn
the pattern bro
i'm literally sweating right now dude
i'm gonna die oh
here we go i can't even get past the
second level
oh my god me and chandler both have one
life
wait what oh gosh this is too quick i'm
better than you chris do you see me
mm-hmm do you believe in me no not at
all
okay you know what i'm not telling you
guys what i'm doing because i'm not
kissing nobody's sock
dude i just can't be in last
oh yeah it's last place sassy oh no your
mom
i hate your mom yeah
it seems pretty easy to me yeah man wait
oh chandler lost his life as well hey
johnny yeah ah
shut up shut up i got a lot going on
here i don't want to kiss a sock you got
last you got last
hey chris i haven't died yet
i haven't died yet either really me and
chandler both have died
i'll challenge that four times instead
of instead of
having lives why don't we see who dies
the most right yeah actually
and we'll just get rid of lives we're
just gonna see how many times we die
yeah
carl's a genius no oh yes
i just oh you're getting pelted oh my
god no what the [ __ ]
oh my gosh she was right there tied baby
i hate my life
chandler did it yes
you have to stay moving and just hold
the space bar and you have to jump
left and right the whole time so the
arrows can't hit you i'm literally
sweating i've never been this nervous in
my entire life
what the hell all right you know what i
quit
i died five times dude the arrows aren't
letting me make the jumps they just hit
me big jumps
i mean maybe if you're bad
i'm having so much fun i love the gaming
channel
channel's my favorite channel jimmy's
gonna stop doing the game i'm gonna just
delete the channel so i don't have to
kiss a sock
oh here he is he's coming around the
bend he'll be coming round the bin when
he comes
so currently i've died five times
chandler has died four times chris and
carl have died zero wait how many did
how many have me and chris died i forgot
i didn't hear you
stop no can they're currently me and you
are fighting to not kiss a sock
oh this one's hard chris chris this
one's hard
all right chris you go first i'm still
going
all right i guess i'm going
oh oh crap there's mobs there's mobs why
are there mobs
there's so many mobs and by so many i
mean one i always do that
i made it by the way i made it this one
was really easy
yeah it was that was way harder there's
there's water in this one i just swam
through most of it so chandler how uh
how's it going it feels good to be in in
the shade brother yeah
did you hit me jimmy no that was an
error
oh god this is the part that's scary
okay here we go ready go
apparently they're getting shot by mobs
watch out for the skelly no oh
no no yeah carl got a boy
not a boy carl carl's the meat shield oh
jimmy's on
uh two one
oh my gosh that one's so hard i'm
getting hit like crazy now
yeah i can't beat it i can't do it it
hates me jimmy you hate
i just watched you eat no oh it looked
like you ate and i heard if i ate would
i have died right there
all right now get out quick
ah yay jimmy made it i died three times
so what am i up to eight do i have eight
deaths chandler has five four
four oh gosh jimmy jimmy guess how many
i have guess how many i have
i don't care zero i'm on a plus two i'm
still within par
i feel like at this point minecraft just
wants me to kiss the sock i think that's
just
what happens it's going to be mine too
who's going first
yes oh no oh no
of course of course of course of course
an arrow knocks me off
oh baby arrow knocked me off chris died
for the first time guys i died for the
first time
what oh wait it literally hits me every
single time right away
what is it doing i'm almost there oh
baby let's go
dude i'm not even chandler
hey how many hearts do you have i have
five uh i have i only lost three and a
half
i finally finally the stupid rng in the
game didn't decide to screw me
oh cool it hit me as i was about this
yeah welcome to my world
now you see how i feel don't you dare
complain i've had that happen for four
maps boo hoo one map it does it to you
your life's so hard oh dude that was so
close see what i'm saying
oh hit him hit him hit him
rng gods make chris full chris
i'm just taking so much damage bro like
it's just hitting me in the randomest
places
i lost five hearts all right there we go
hey here you go i have no reason to
sabotage anybody i'm so in the lead
right now
hey carl i got a thousand dollars that
could have your name on if you go kill
some people
oh i'm i'm freaking cooking whatever you
guys say doesn't mean anything oh my
gosh
what what do i do what do i do your boy
out here eating
your boy yeah having so much fun chris
hello hello so much fun who gave me a
steak
it's for the end oh just know i didn't
eat it though
yeah why i only have one heart i only
have one heart i'm throwing away all the
steak so i don't even think about it
stop
that's evil that was sad that was wrong
we're counting it but that was wrong
hey wait is this
okay guys come to come to my room come
here boys
come here all right chris take off your
socks i came in last place
eat my socks hey you said four seconds
by the way
hey look on that green screen all the
footage of you died
all right subscribe i want to barf oh my
god
our green screen i hope my girlfriend
doesn't watch this video she'll probably
never let me kiss her again
so guys do not whatever you do tweet
this at maddie tweeted it maddie i want
her